let's say that you are an ancient
philosopher who is building up
mathematics from the ground up and you
already have a reasonable understanding
of what a negative number could or
should represent and you know how to add
and subtract negative numbers but now
you are faced with a conundrum what
happens when you multiply negative
numbers either when you multiply a
positive number times a negative number
or when you multiply two negative
numbers so for example you aren't quite
sure what should happen if you were to
multiply and i'm just picking two
numbers where one is positive and one is
negative what would happen if you were
to multiply five times negative three
you're not quite sure about this just
yet you're also not quite sure about
what would happen if you multiply two
negative numbers so let's say negative
two
times negative six this is also unclear
to you what you do know because you are
a mathematician is however you define
this or whatever this should be it
should hopefully be consistent with all
of the other
properties of mathematics that you
already know and preferably all of the
other properties of multiplication that
would make you feel comfortable that you
are getting this right and later we can
think about other ways to get the
intuition for what these might be and
why it actually makes sense but to make
this consistent with the rest of the
mathematics that you know you and you go
into a little bit of a thought
experiment you say well what should
times 3
plus negative 3b well you already have a
philosophy of adding negative numbers or
adding positive to negative numbers you
know that negative 3 is the opposite of
3.
if you add 3 to negative 3 you're going
to get 0. so this is going to be equal
to this is going to be equal to 5 times
5 times 0 based on how you already
thought about adding a negative to a
positive and anything times 0 is going
to be 0. so this expression right over
here should be 0. but on the other hand
you say well i want i want multiplying
positive and negative numbers to be
consistent with the distributive
property so i should be able to
distribute this 5 i should be able to
distribute this 5 and for math to be
consistent and math should be consistent
i should get the exact same answer so
let's distribute this 5. so if we get 5
times 3 so 5 times 3 is going let me
write it out this is going to be 5 times
and let me write it with the
multiplication not the dot i'll write
the x sign for for multiplying 5 times 3
so i distribute it there
plus
5 times negative three and i'll do that
in yellow
five times negative three five times
negative three and this whole thing we
just said should be equal to zero
this should be equal to zero well five
times three those are two positive
numbers we know what that should be that
is going to be fifteen so now we get
this thing fifteen
plus
plus whatever five times negative three
is
plus whatever 5 times negative 3 is
needs to be equal to 0 in order to be
consistent with all of the other
mathematics that we know
well what plus 15 is going to be equal
to 0 well the opposite of 15. in order
for this to be true in order for this to
be consistent with all of the other
mathematics we know
this right over here
needs to be equal to negative 15. and so
you say 5 times negative 3 in order to
be consistent with all the other
mathematics we know needs to be equal to
negative 15. and that's also consistent
with the intuition of adding negative
three repeatedly five times
now a slightly harder to conceive idea
is multiplying two negatives but we can
do the exact same thought experiment we
want whatever this answer to be to be
consistent with the rest of mathematics
that we know so we can say
so we could do the same thought
experiment what would negative 2
times 6 plus negative 6 be equal to well
6 plus negative 6 is going to be 0
negative 2 times 0 anything times 0
needs to be equal to
0 but then once again we can distribute
we can distribute negative two times six
so we get negative two
negative two times six
plus
plus negative two times negative six
negative two times negative 6 and once
again all of that's going to need to be
equal to 0. now based on the thought
experiment we just did we said well this
needs to be equal to negative 12. or we
could view this as
going to the 6 twice in the left
direction on the number line which would
get us to negative 12 or you could say
repeatedly adding negative 2 6 times
that would also get you to negative 12
and now we also saw it over here that we
multiplied a positive times a negative
we got tonight we we got the negative
so this could be or we know that this is
going to be equal to negative 12. and so
we had negative 12 plus
plus whatever this business is
whatever this business is is going to
have to be equal to 0
is going to have to be equal to 0 in
order to be consistent with all of the
other mathematics that we know
and so what plus negative 12 is going to
be equal to 0
well positive 12 plus negative 12 is
going to be equal to 0. so this needs to
be equal to positive 12 in order to be
consistent with all of the other
mathematics we know and so there we get
the idea that this is going to be
positive
positive 12. i'll leave you there and
i'll see if i can make a few other
videos that can also give you a
conceptual understanding of why these
are true